[Music]
mother out of love news okay Val you're
about to throw up
submitted by to Molly aunt Rita what
maybe like a like a goods trader no you
gotta get your assassins out scared of
that an 83 year old mom was shelled
mercy by the court after explaining why
she murdered her disabled son all was it
mercy killing oh my god mercy killing
because her son was disabled that she
was like mom please take me out I can't
live like this anymore
take me out like oh gee I don't want to
die like a [ __ ]
so this mother from China nothing okay
so from China is always reacted when I
said I loved I never yeah so anyways she
had spent 46 years of her life looking
after her disabled son what a trooper
thank you can we give her a round of
applause please
thank you that's so nice but then at the
same time it's like duh what else are
you gonna do you have to take care of
your son right like giving her a [ __ ]
trophy for doing normal [ __ ] so so she's
83 years old right her more than like
half of her life she's been taking care
of her son he has severe he was born
with severe disabilities and so he's but
he was bad the way he was like a b-minus
student severe disabilities is a P minus
is so we've hadded we got a 3.5 GPA dude
that'd be hilarious it this whole story
she's just talking about her with shitty
ass son but he just works a normal job
this weird product to take care of an
everyday feed him porridge like mama
good alright miss white yeah I told you
I'm American educated I'm a ABC
I know [ __ ] man Jesus no he wasn't he
was bedridden he had severe mental
disability hmm well we gotta say this
guy cuz i Piggy's a normal Chinese guy
it could be you it could be yeah cuz
that's how my mom talks to me that's
true
she's like why don't I get that [ __ ]
blue tag look at my son I know my mom my
Asian standards I could get the handicap
card that's true so there she was saying
that by the time her son reached the age
of 30 his condition worsened even more
he got becomes much cooler dystrophy oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and so for the last two
years she says that her health has
deteriorated and so she is like a burden
of taking care of him on to anyone else
so she felt like the only thing she
could really do is just to put him out
herself with her as well and how does
she do it so she gave him sixty sleeping
pills oh my god and then strangled him
oh yeah what I'm a little confused she
why did she have to strangle I met
through the 60 sleeping yeah why is
there double that's like I shot him and
then I mutilated his body maybe it's to
prevent him from throwing at you know
the site because I translated it it says
that she suffocated him but then the
other site says strangled so I don't
know what I did it yeah but still yeah
not too different strangle a woman but
it's still addition to the sleeping yes
yeah yeah you know it's double I'm
picturing this is like she first of all
grinding up 60 pills that's enough she
grows I'm hoping hopefully she grounded
up and put in porridge is what I'm
hoping I thought she's sucking into the
dumplings Wow they just say yeah and
then she gives it like he's already
knocked out that she goes I'm so sad she
was pardoned yeah I thought she was okay
okay pardon at all
she was she was shown mercy in my head
it took it that way you could like like
the judge heard it was like what that
may sir
no because he also had a brother so then
and people were like well I couldn't you
know why do the brother just take care
of it so she was like I don't want
anyone in this world like I brought him
into the world I took care of him this
whole time this should not be anyone
elses bird it's not her decision to make
right cuz like if I was the brother I'm
like mom what the [ __ ] dude I could have
kept I could have took care of him
that's my brother yeah so because of
that reason the fact that like no one
should ever make the decision to take
someone else's life that would be for
that reason the judge sentenced her to
three years in prison and four years
since suspended sentence
so probation maybe yeah so they're
saying like because she was over the age
of 75 years old maybe dead anyways and
they're giving her a lighter sentence
for what she did well his soul did this
her child had muscular dystrophy right
in addition to a lot of others because a
my my parents stored there was one of
our customers her kid her kid had it and
I saw that kid dwindle yeah like fast
like he was like it was like straight up
crutches to wheelchair couldn't move
yeah then he passed away so I forgot
what the time span was but it wasn't
that long it was like in a few years and
he passed
yeah cuz there affects your organs too
like all of your organs are involuntary
muscle so if I must muscular dystrophy
everything's gonna atrophy yeah after
she killed her son she immediately
contacted the police and just honorable
lady what I don't understand is the
pills and the [ __ ] choking oh man I
had to throw myself well maybe maybe
what if he threw out the threw up the
pills or like what if they rushed into
the ER to pump out all the toxins and he
can still survive I think one is like
here's the pills yeah die peacefully and
then it clicked into my life
[Music]
it's like it's like here's the rat
poison but let me hit you over the head
with a hammer at the same yeah she was
showing him some mercy and she's just
like I still think it's all [ __ ] up
but she was just like oh I see he's like
you might feel painting or something so
here let me just help him go fast
one little painful you have been choked
up before he melts [ __ ] sucks
suffocating Toki which is worse what
depends on the choke are we talking
about like an artery juggler talking
about like taking out the [ __ ] I
don't know talk like a blood or like
this because if it's a blood show I
think a blood sugar yeah so like you
know in a rear naked choke that's a
blood choke so you just stop the carotid
arteries and then you just slow the
black out you know you're still
breathing that you're black you know
blood flow it gets cut but if it's an
aerco holding her neck and I'm pressing
her windpipe she's like literally
choking when she's Johnny with it but
air choke is different well I believe it
was a quote so she put one of those
[ __ ] tiger why can't you send her
thank him to uh caretakers home she was
like no oh [ __ ]
I am the only one that should be taken
care of you know I could kind of
understand her train of thought because
uh so my dad this is a way later but my
dad uh gonna do so Mike my dad wait wait
my dad can't turn his neck so all you
just see the ice shift so he's like move
your [ __ ] chair we had a rabbit tight
then we're going like on weekly checkups
and I was telling him that like Oh
nowadays they can detect if there's
multiple chromosomes down to anomaly all
that stuff right here's like oh really
he goes well if you know that your
child's not right you know what to do
right
no mine what do you mean yes I know oh
my what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding
me but he was there
like past the the date of life he was
like what how many months he's like six
a six month mine or something yeah I'd
like me but then he's like yeah but then
just in case the computers are wrong oh
he's like and if the baby comes out he
goes and I was like where you trying to
get to let me know we got to go to
another country and dump them off he
goes maybe do you know I'm like you are
a refugee ass [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] crazy so like so I think like
with that traditional old-school refugee
ass thinking like I can see where like I
make you I can kill you
yeah I can trick with the grandma it
makes sense because China had the
one-child policy and you know sometimes
there's a baby that come out that's not
a boy well it's not what you want or
yeah it's only got three legs I mean
it's only got three limbs you know like
it's just you're always thinking of your
dog so interesting that after X amount
of years of knowing your father he could
still surprise you yeah crazy [ __ ] all
the time it's like your dad just comes
up he goes well you know with your other
brothers and sisters they didn't make it
through the go game like you know you're
number six right was it like some
Chinese Spartan village where they try
to have genetically perfect people and
in like that's what I thought it's like
a Spartan
like 300 when they throw the kids over
there oh my god I'll be throwing the
cliff so fast before me do you know what
to do even get you over the cliff
you know what's so funny somebody's [ __ ]
again you know that film it was supposed
to be a very light heartwarming part is
that Hunchback with when he was holding
up the shield
it was super strong and he couldn't lift
it up ah boy spit up laughing in the
[ __ ] theater oh the only one laughing
I'm not used trying to show off
yeah lift your shield oh man what a
great film you know that character it
was just a normal like sheep herder and
they [ __ ] hated the Spartans oh
really
yeah because the Spartans were big
bullies they will come out and just when
they're going on their campaigns they're
just like hey give me those [ __ ]
sheep give me that thing they'll just
take it from people around them so what
their bosses [ __ ] though but then when
the Persians came they're like hey I'll
[ __ ] show you where around that
little cave [ __ ] the perp you know [ __ ]
these guys so that's what yeah the
Spartans they were the varsity football
team yeah you got to be nice to
everybody even the sheep herders like me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]